Christian says that you've got some
special thing planned yeah it's like a
crazy nine-day festival all right hello
hello and hello everyone out there my
name is Eric Davis I am thrilled to be
here today for a conversation about the
upcoming film mid Samar it hits theaters
on July 3rd everywhere and with the film
we have director writer director arias
stirrer and the stars Florence Pugh and
Jack Rayner hello everyone well thank
you for being here very excited to talk
about this film LOX I would say Ari you
know one thing I want to start out with
first nobody's seen this movie yet but
one person has seen this movie and so I
want to share one of the first reactions
from this film is from a gentleman named
Jordan Peele is a writer director of get
out and us and so I just want to read I
want to get your reaction to what he is
reaction to the film so Jordan Peele
said I think you've made the most
idyllic horror film of all time you've
taken Stepford Wives and shattered the
attractiveness of that movie with this
one that alone is a feat also there are
some obvious comps out there but this
movie is just so unique this hasn't
existed yet and anything after mid Samar
is going to have to contend with it I
mean this uncertain is the most iconic
Paiva movie to be referenced high praise
yeah my first reaction is that he's lost
all credibility but yeah he saw a very
early cut before he's out very early cut
before like any VFX
sound max color music so I just wonder
what next week but I mean it is high
praise you know and I think you
alongside Jordan Peele I think we're
doing very interesting things in the
genre right now and telling you can't
just say their horror movies because I
think there's so much other layers to it
audiences will be most familiar with you
due to the sort of the breakout hit of
your
last film which was hereditary and I
think that film had a lot of different
things going on with it was a family
drama it had some sort of cult ashiness
vibes to it some some occult stuff so I
guess the first question that a lot of
audience members have and I'll give to
you is how does this separate itself
from hereditary myths Amara
I mean aesthetically like the
differences are pretty clear one is very
dark and one is very bright
if anything I'm I've become pretty
struck by how similar they are they are
in different ways both films are very
much about family red eteri I guess was
sort of a film about family dysfunction
and this is something of a horror film
about codependency bad breakup I've
heard you compare the describe this film
as both an adult fairytale and a bad
breakup movie yeah that that that that's
still the only way I really feel
comfortable describing the film it's
it's a it's an operatic breakup movie
and and a dark contemporary fairy tale
that's that's what it is
and which sounds amazing the two people
who are breaking up in the movie are
played by YouTube so why don't we start
by telling us what about these roles and
what about this film sort of attracted
you to them well you know I am
I met re kind of at the beginning of
2018 and we sat to him to talk about the
film and I'd read the script and and I
think like there was one version of my
character at least on paper who was just
kind of like an unforgiveable dick
basically
that you know was pretty OneNote but
within the way it was written I could
see how actually you know maybe there's
a part of this guy who's just kind of
looking for his autonomy a little bit
and you know is not you know he's just
reached the end of his ability to
participate in the relationship and I
was really intrigued about working with
Arie to find a way to you know kind of
like portray that in a not cut and dry
way you know where the kind of moral
lines were a bit muddy and you know
where it wasn't just a kind of like
singular sort of vision for the
character where there was a bit bit of
room to play with it and so I think that
you know the experience of shooting it
with re you know he kind of like let me
do whatever I wanted to do with the
character and find as much of that kind
of dynamic kind of energy with him as
possible so and that was what I did and
it was really really enjoyable that was
what I had hoped for before we set to
set to work on the film and that was
definitely what I got and then you know
haven't seen re her edit arey hadn't
come out at the time so I hadn't seen
hereditary but I'd seen all of our
shorts before that and I just thought
like this guy is an astonishing
filmmaker like what an incredible vision
that he has you know and so I was really
really excited to to work with me kind
of get behind there got behind the film
re and I first so I was filming a series
little drummer girl at the time and I
was in Athens and her energy was just
about to come out and just as was about
to come out there were all these
whispers about midsummer that was gonna
happen that summer and my team was so
excited by it and I read this read the
script and they were like look if you're
gonna Skype anyone right now we know
you're busy but if you're gonna Skype
anyone it's gonna be re and I was like
like read the script amazing and I came
back from a night shoot at like 4:00
a.m. and we Skyped and we were both so
exhausted usually at these things
whenever you Skype a director you never
you never really finished the
conversation you go like okay well well
see what happens in the conversation
with our agents and we were both so
exhausted that we ended the call with
like look I would I would love to do it
would you have me and he was like yeah
I'd love to have you I mean great cool
so we both went to bed having accepted
this without telling our agents which
was great and then I think the biggest
thing for me that kind of I was really
really terrified because I've never I as
Florence have never come close to
anything in terms of my life trauma wise
and pain wise and grief wise I haven't
come it's like anywhere near the the
emotional pain that Danny goes through
so I was wisely terrified about that
because they didn't I don't think it's
suddenly you could just give it a go
like I knew that it was very important
and that did scare me actually going
into it I had I had no idea how to
access that but it was the same kind of
fear that really excited me into
figuring out who this woman was and and
why she was running away from I suppose
dealing with it head-on and I mean it
was wicked we got out there and within
we had like a week of rehearsals and in
in that week we did improv as a couple
and Ari was the therapist a couple yeah
and the first thing that when we
finished okay we punched you in the face
I was and when he came to me as well no
kidding
the first thing that he said when we
finished you Youth I remember you saying
you like I just feel the weight of the
guilt
and that's this such this whole
relationship was that it's it was just
it's so heavy and so intense and we had
a great time shooting it but it was like
it's an intense Fellman that the the
stuff that we were doing was pretty well
we're gonna be weary we're not spoiling
anything just yeah there's no spoilers
here but we we do want to know you know
what can you tell us about this film
obviously Florence's character is
dealing with a lot of trauma a lot of
grief in our past and now a breakup with
this guy Wow or maybe a breakup and then
they're going they're going to a
festival of some kind so what can you
say sort of give us a little bit of a
setup for the film for people who aren't
as familiar with it look at the walls
I think that's yeah and don't pause
don't pause and zoom in don't like be
wait about it just look at the walls see
what your interpretation is what you're
ready for and you will be the pariah
yeah yeah just look at the walls but no
I mean yeah tell us about you know just
to set up and maybe where the
inspiration for the film came from and I
had heard that maybe it was a little bit
personal for you that had something to
do with with your own experiences in
your own life and so just talk about
where it where's where it came from
yeah well you know um I I wanted to when
I was writing the film I mean I wanted
to write a breakup movie because I
needed to write a breakup movie because
I had just gone through a breakup okay
and and I saw a way of sort of passing
it through this sub-genre the folk
horror genre and
you know marrying those two things and
and you know finding a way to make this
big operatic just break breakup movie
dark comedy I don't know I don't know
what it is okay she raises funny I hope
it's funny I think it's great that it's
a little bit of all of these different
things it's not you can't just say it's
a horror movie cuz it's not just the
heart yeah if anything it's it's really
it's just it's such a crescendo in all
yeah and like a hundred percent on
everything it's it's it's moving upward
towards something kind of grand which is
sort of similar to her yeah I was gonna
say that and we actually had some fans
ask us you know because hereditary is
sort of a bit of a slow build and then
the floor drops out from underneath you
and you're sitting with your mouth open
for the last 10 minutes you're like yep
that's fine that's totally normal okay
oh okay well should audiences expect
sort of a similar adventure yes and no I
mean I I gosh I I don't I said I don't
know I don't I I don't know I I'm so
close to both films that I in a way I I
have no objectivity but I do hope that
you know viewers are you know unfolded
in this world and that they get lost in
it and that it that they maybe get lost
enough in it that you know
the ending which is you know pretty
prolonged comes as a surprise and an
emotional surprise is this a film if
you've just gone through a breakup this
is a film that you please that's a
loaded question I don't know it depends
on who you are if you like vindication
maybe it's a universal what can we what
can we say a balance this festival I
think it's it's interesting is this
based on a real festival that they go to
is is it part real part create fictional
what is this festival that they go to as
much as you can say about you
I mean it's drawn from some crazy stuff
there's a lot of music it's it's drawn
from a lot of research so there's a lot
of actual tradition that's sort of
buried in the film there's a lot of
folklore I mean I was pulling from a lot
of different spiritual movements that
have nothing to do in many cases with
even Sweden but yeah I mean there are
hundreds of things kind of woven
together here in the look the launching
off point for you was folklore yes I
would say what was the launching off
point
yeah sure folklore well I would cuz I've
read a little bit over like like
Scandinavian folklore it's got all kinds
of creatures and monsters in it and is
that sort of stuff that help kind of
played into it at all in no there's
there's nothing overtly you know
fantastical here gosh I reckon like from
just from the experience of making the
film and being from Ireland which is
obviously an incredibly superstitious
place where there's a lot of folk
culture going on like one of the best
things about the story of the film is
that like the relationship and the kind
of social norms in which we exist like
the the lens through which you're
viewing that in this film is really
distorted by this like sense of like
there's a tradition and that there's
like a folk element behind it so you're
kind of watching it going we'll wait
from an anthropological point of view
this is just kind of what these people
maybe do you know so you're always kind
of on edge and not knowing well maybe
it's kind of okay maybe I don't know
maybe how much can you get away with how
much of this horror are we gonna buy
into before we as like the society that
we leave and go oh [ __ ] no this is wrong
you know this is like [ __ ] off and
that was what I loved about make and
that was the the interesting thing for
me the folk element of it that was
really interesting was that it being a
you know kind of like they're like
there's so much mythology and there's so
much so much of this and history that we
don't know much about kind of leading us
through the film and it kind of blurs
the lines and like it kind of throws the
question open like how much of this are
we willing to accept and how far are we
willing to go into this before we decide
that it's obscene you know yeah that's
like I think that's pretty masterful
filmmaking to be fair going on at do you
mind I love you so fascinating too is
that it's it's it's set at a time where
there's just daylight all the time and
so if it's if it's bright and everything
looks like a beautiful painting is it is
it harder to make the
scary when it's so bright and so
beautiful or doesn't even become even
scarier when it's so bright it's so
beautiful what I will say is one of the
things that I really did realize later
on in the day yesterday I watched it
yesterday at turn with Ari and I didn't
really know what to say afterwards and
what I did end up realizing hours later
was how much how many like graphic
images I had seen without truly noting
them as being something horrific it was
just totally beautiful and that was down
to like cinematography palette color
lighting and you don't and until later
do you realize what was actually
happening in that scene and in that
moment when you're watching like god
that's beautiful
god I love the color of red but you're
just so kind of in it and and everything
is so exciting and and vibrant on on all
your senses like music sight I mean I
wish you could eat something whilst
watching it but yeah okay yeah you know
but like the Swedish food everything
it's an egg yolk it's amazing to like
watch it I don't think I've ever watched
a film before whether it's like so much
darkness like right in the middle of
like this blistering light you know and
I mean like the whole thing is like lit
in such a way where just everything is
there there's no shadows in any corners
but there's a darkness everywhere you
know that's which is wild and I don't
think we've ever really seen a film like
that before
yeah I can't thank you on yeah I've
heard the shoot was kind of arduous for
you guys no talk about that what was so
arduous what was so difficult well yes I
mean he didn't eat for three months I
had to force feed him protein bars in
the morning and then I'd come back to
him like an hour late I'd be like are
did you hit the ball and he gonna have
like a half-eaten bar like a bar
[Laughter]
no I mean it was hard we you know we
were chasing the Sun every day
which means that you're just desperately
trying to avoid continuity errors which
you can't because you're not shooting
this where it's sunlight 24 hours
shooting this no we didn't shoot in
Sweden we shot in Hungary in which you
know they're shorter days there but I
mean if you're if you know there were
days where we would have to shoot ten
scenes in a day which ultimately means
that you you're you're bummed you're
bumping up against continuity problems
less then you know the days when you're
shooting one scene over the course of a
day because the Sun is by the you know
in the morning the Sun is in one place
in the afternoon it's it's it's done a
180 and the shadows have shifted I feel
like I'm just like alerting people to
what the storyline means that that is
totally okay yeah yeah I'm gonna solve
it helped actually yeah I I know that my
my cinematographer Pavel public jail ski
and I we we were panicked throughout the
shooting because we didn't know how how
much how well the the content would hold
up to scrutiny and and we're I think
both relieved that you can just watch
the movie one of the big kickers as well
with the whole that hull components of
chasing the light throughout every day
because we're also we're shooting in a
valley so late you know there's like
shadows everywhere at a certain time we
didn't really have that many hours in
the day to shoot the light the way it
needed to be shot right but add to that
the fact that you've got a portion of
people on Sat speak in English a portion
of people on Sat speaking Hungarian and
a portion of people speaking Swedish
we've got three different primary
languages going on and set and how many
people spoke all three maybe one no so
like it was it was incredibly arduous to
coordinate anything that needed to be
done needed to be translated and
understood by everyone in order to
progress and to do anything which I mean
that was pretty hard
[Laughter]
the biggest scenes at times everybody
left us everybody everyone left when he
is that better though if nobody's there
and if you have a really really
difficult scene or people there I don't
know maybe this one it would have been
nice to have a couple roommates that
would drink for all of us they take away
the content the like just the heat that
we were shooting in it was it was really
hot we were in a field that's like a
small airport yeah well an airstrip
where planes were taking off every five
minutes and killing our same apartment
so it's just like okay stop we gotta
stop for until their plane yeah there'd
be like three World War one body planes
just from the content that we were
shooting it was like it was it was it
was meaty so yeah it's always nice to
have a pal to go and have a neat drink
with after yeah I was wearing my Safari
oh yeah he's terrified of bugs
he had like they said the Gator socks
that went over
in the foods and then then you know the
beekeepers hot you have and then the
beekeepers gloves that guy was colonial
look but they would be green green
Gators they weren't even like a normal
color they were like bright fluorescent
green or a bug okay I made it yeah
anyway it's a great fellow you should go
watch it
talk about Easter eggs are there Easter
eggs in this film what can people who
are sort of nerds about that kind of
stuff
look look at the wall the wall you know
that we've launched the walls in the
film yeah I mean there there are a lot
of there's a lot of peripheral
information that that connects to other
stuff and a lot of stuff that's a lot of
prophetic detail that you know if you
don't catch it then you'll you know
hopefully you'll still enjoy the film
but it but if you if you do catch it I
think it it encourages like you know
maybe a more active investment or
engagement you know with the material
brands for multiple viewings well I was
gonna say is it sounds like the kind of
film that you really need to watch yeah
a lot of it like heritage tree like I
didn't notice half of the stuff that
happened in that until they washed it a
second time when I was like oh she's all
know Xena it's not quite like this a
little but I do remember one day like we
were doing this really intense scene and
then Ari went and like wizard me over
and points the monitor and as he pointed
I was like oh my god all because there
was something on the wall watch the
watch that's like the biggest tip that
we're getting here
oh my god I've already seen the film
twice I'm just looking at the walls I
watched what's that interview and I was
very disappointed what do you hope
audiences take away from this film you
guys have indication I don't know I
really feel like you know like for me at
least making the film it feels like
something from you know another time if
this is not a conventional horror movie
it doesn't feel like it fits into any
boxes and my favorite thing when I go to
the theater and I see a movie is when
you know I watched something that is
unique and striking and seems to be
taking things in a different direction
and I really feel like that's something
that this movie is down and it's
capitalizing on the prestige of what is
a conventional horror that we've had
over the past go into ten years and I
think it's taking it to a different
level so I hope people are gonna walk
out of the theater feeling the same way
which sounds refreshing so if you're
looking for something if your horror and
you're looking for something completely
original and unique and you're a big set
of five I probably wanted you know a
time
Florence what about you what do you what
do you hope people take away I have no
idea I'm really I honestly I haven't
watched it yesterday I thought watching
the film was gonna make me it was gonna
make things a lot clearer and it hasn't
it's actually just complicated and
everything so I don't I already know if
you were gonna take from other it's so
stimulating like what I was talking
about earlier everything you are just
shot with this injection of color and
sound and just visual beauty and to the
point where you don't even really
realize that what you saw was awful like
so I don't know what people will take
for because there are so many different
kind of pathways of of this storyline
but it's certainly colorful last words
from the writer director what do you
hope I just hope people are you know
transported and moved and and confused
yeah I'd be great at this moving
transportation and confusion at once I
[Laughter]
hope they get from A to B well the film
is mid Samara comes out July 3rd arias
Lafleur's peu Jack Rayner thank you so
much for being here for this
conversation watch the walls when you
watch the film and and good luck thank
you thank you we only do this every 90
years
I was most excited for you to come
[Music]